[Music]
hello any better get in there can you
all hear me over there back good
Scot Morrie if you're happy I'm happy
welcome everybody what a great program
we just had from all the speakers it was
really exciting and we got a lot of
great comments which was really nice and
gratifying for us we've been at this for
a while we'll talk about it and show you
some slides to that effect
my name is Ralph Oregon I'm the
associate vice president for campus
design and facility development it's our
group that has the responsibility at the
University to hire the architect hire
the contractor and then project manages
we go through and if you saw the video
these buildings are really easy to build
they think like you know four minutes
you're done so we have here a very
distinguished group of folks who have
been our partners in this project for
multiple years and I want to start with
an to Riley the director of construction
Bob Raffy is our director of design and
planning buzz you Dell of more ruble and
you know and Jeff Kaplan from a
pollution management who's david's chief
operating officer and has been our David
Whisperer for four years and this fella
here the cyclist
who's been to the orthopedic doctor
three times since we started this
project is Brian Rutledge so we're gonna
have questions at the end but I think if
people you know we got a pretty good
group here if anybody wants to jump in
just raise your hand and we'll see if we
can't do it but Brian brought Lajoie
stinks up the craziest photographs there
may be popped up this one up but uh I
think is the Andrew Carnegie in that one
we don't know we think this we think
that's actually a mrs. hammer Schlag
where somebody like that okay so years
ago and then GSI a the graduate school
of industrial Administration was a new
idea way back when and then the Tempur
school which eventually became the
Tempur school began to grow Andrew
actually when he was with the private
construction firm helped to build the
Posner Hall that was in addition and you
can see here but we ran out of room to
grow the we had the original building
and then in 1970 it was added on to in
1980 we got the Cooper Simon classrooms
can you see the dates and 1993 was
Posner Hall and then in 2000 we added
the Florida Posner Hall so you can see
in the Krause Campo came in in 2005 so
there was there was just no place to
grow and I think David and others while
we did the 2009 edition as well in the
Peace Garden so that we said here we go
well there's the blue wall we had to put
that in
that's a blue wall under construction
which was also a big impetus for our
temper quad project for those of you who
know the story we'll skip them so I'd
like Bob to go through these slides Bob
is we we stole Bob from City Planning
and he is a brilliant thinker and does
the work of three people he's
extraordinary and I think connects well
with our architects is our fixer
downtown with things City Planning and
Zoning and I'll click the slides Bob if
you sort of walk through them so thanks
Rob so cool that's Wow as long as it
sounds like to me I know I told my
didn't need a mic my wife reminds me of
that all the time
so back in 2010 when we were looking at
this we started thinking about we knew
we didn't have enough room as Ralph
showed the slides of old GSA Posner how
we had run out of room we like to say
that that building is the poster child
for incremental institutional expansion
added on to seven times over its 50-year
lifespan and so we said okay well what
if we're not good we can't do any more
kind of band-aids at that site let's
look at other sites and so we kind of
cast a wide net at the entirety of
campus we looked everywhere from the
south of forbes site the site we're
sitting on of course the more wood a lot
with it even at the tennis courts at
skeebo gym and if you look at the next
slide you can see but that we then we
actually comparable and when we came
down to it at the end of them only one
of them was just right the south of
forums was just a little too far away
from campus the tennis courts was maybe
just too small to get all the program we
needed on it if you haven't been in the
building it's big adhere the skeebo Jim
who had a historic building on it so the
goldilocks site really was this one that
were standing at and which was really
exciting because we had for many years
talked about the expansion of campus
across Forbes Avenue and the growth of
the campus and this is the kind of
future of campus so he took this site
however if you looked at our master plan
that we were dealing with in 2010 our
master plan had different ideas our
master plan talked about at that
when active the site we're sitting on is
going to be an academic building but
also a soccer field which is kind of
sitting there in the middle of it and so
we really needed to kind of start
rethinking what that meant as we wanted
to grow we wanted to grow campus what
did that mean is move forward so if we
advanced up so that they're showing the
soccer field and the site that became
now the Tempur quad next slide zoomed in
on so we started to look at campus and
this is a shot from this is the 2012
master plan and we started looking at
where the growth patterns were and if
you've been hanging around around campus
for the last five years we've had lots
of ground breakings which is very very
exciting
everything from Scott Hall to the work
at Hamburg Hall to the Cohen Center
expansion that I opened a couple years
ago if you stick around not too long
from now we'll have a big opening for
ANSYS Hall in about a year from now so
that's all very exciting and all of that
growth kind of showed as you started to
move towards the north and at across
Forbes Avenue and that is where the
Tempur quad really was born so as you
start to see as we zoom into this area
we look at it if you notice there's that
kind of triangular building Forbes is
running through the site we're at the
building on the left hand side of the
image here and there's that triangular
building immediately we started
readjusting the master plan you'll see
in the next image as we advanced we
eliminated that building created the
Tempur quad identified where this new
big building that's new home for The
Temper School of Business and the other
functions were and we adjusted the
master plan accordingly and next thing
you know while we have the temper quad
which we're very excited now this is the
first building in it of course the
temper quad was not exactly attached
easily to campus many people asked where
we're gonna put a bridge to get over to
the temper quad which we decided not to
do and say in fact we started doing a
number of other things we started
increasing and improving the pedestrian
connections we added traffic lights you
saw our temporary versions that are out
there right now that will become the
permit those are become new permanent
traffic lights to get people across
Forbes Avenue onto campus we started
extending utilities like steam lines and
chill water lines through a tunnel that
enters
we brought of electricity onto this site
we brought in data this of course is
Carnegie Mellon we love our data so all
of these things and of course we had to
deal with getting things off of the site
so where we were going to put our sewer
lines that all these things started to
knit the site ready to go
so with that goddess then in about
2013-14 when we brought Buzz and Brian
onto the scene is now we have a site
ready to go so we the idea is if you
look at the next slide we have we have
next one here we go this one we started
with this is our idea and if this was
for you Brian of our building seed and
so the question is how do we get from
that with this idea to the next slide
well which is where we're sitting right
now so I guess I'm going to turn it over
to Brian to talk about that next Brian
Rutledge has been unbelievable we
probably had you in 250 meetings oh yes
I'm very productive but Brian very
level-headed steered us out of danger
many times and his wit is unparalleled
he gave a talk usually when the there's
something called the Society for college
and university planning or scup and they
had the regional conference here
recently and usually it's people like me
who speak and I said well they want to
have fun and they came to campus let's
put Brian on the stage and the first
thing what was the first thing you put
up on the on the screen far side cartoon
personality type by far side cartoon so
to this day we're still hearing from our
professionals and peers around the
country about that guy that gave that
talk at scope he was unbelievable I have
Scott listed on my CV so so thank you
the and for those of you you're asked
this did not happen while on the bike
bike riding is very safe it is falling
off your bike that is
it's to be avoided quickly right yes
there are no easy way off the bike and
timing is everything so so in in 2014
our youngest was in first grade at
Winchester Thurston and they do a little
unit on architecture and so hey I know
an architect so Bob repu and I toured
the first grade around to show them the
business the site of the business school
of the future if you look at that
picture you can see they are very
skeptical this is a tough crowd we're
dealing with here and so what happened
shortly after that when I said we're
building the business school the future
here it expected this to be ok let's you
know move on they what's that all right
why do you need that oh those seem to be
some good questions so we quickly handed
out Oreos and moved on but indeed that
is a good question and sense of what is
it you're trying to do with building a
new building in the sense of you know
building a new building just to get a
nicer building is nice but it's not
really gonna move things and not going
to be very transformative and so there
was a lot of thought and background some
of it was you know just in time
processing and so the ideas were just
catching up as we were digging tunnels
under the under Forbes Avenue and so the
the y part sort of comes from that this
by the way is my favorite picture of old
GSA a when it was just it's steel
structure in the sense of all the
potential that happened there but that's
now the past so what comes from the sort
of idea that's sort of behind most of
the building and and the design that you
see now is this idea that things are
inherently interconnected now in ways
that are much more important and so my
quick summary of this is business
problems are not just business so if you
think of it
take any I don't know old school
business grad MBA student goes off and
gets a job at you
I don't afford right you know it's
relatively straightforward know some
finance and accounting not really
anymore right so if you want to go work
at Ford you need to understand robotic
cars which means understanding Big Data
artificial intelligence but also if you
think about it's not just understanding
the mechanics behind AI and the
engineering it's also the fact that Wow
reporter robotic cars are going to
transform society in ways that we
haven't really thought about these are
fundamental transformative changes and
you know while you were thinking you
want to do is go get a job at four and
so the idea is that if you're going to
be a business student now you're not
just taking classes in finance and
accounting you need to be connected to
these deeper richer areas around
Carnegie Mellon and Carnegie Mellon is a
fantastic place for this and so this is
a natural thing to add other side of
this which i think is part of the the
genius of the whole plan that comes
together is all problems our business in
the sense that this is the this kind of
two-way street about this so if you take
any big societal challenge now there's a
big chunk of this that needs to
understand the business side so I don't
know take climate change with a
hurricane bearing down the East Coast
and you think about all of the science
behind climate change that you can
discuss and understand you know you get
oceanography got to be some biology in
there there's a whole bunch of different
components but if you want to understand
how it's gonna impact things or you want
to affect change you got to run this at
some point through the boardroom and so
this is the sense of which you need to
understand how business works and so
this is part of this kind of
interconnected vision that is the
business school that's here so to do
this the big component of this one of
the big components of this is the where
component so let me click through this
quickly because you saw those earlier
slides so that this is buzz put this
slide earlier together and I've been
stealing it ever since
so the temper school is right at the
heart of that figure eight which is the
Business School is right at the center
of campus now and so it's at the center
of campus you gotta you gotta Bend me
some non-euclidean geography if you
geography if you want right Chris is
pretty spectacle sceptical fair enough
but what we are is we are really busy
right in the sense that this is way
different from the way you build
business schools in the past business
schools used to be off at the edge of
campus because you didn't want your
business students bumping into anybody
who wasn't a business student because
they're very gentle and you don't want a
break coming you know they're like like
orchids or way off in the edge no it you
are right in the heart of it now and you
see this here in the sense of the that
path that's out there is just there's
just thousands of you know students
passing by and they're all come into our
big hobby to get a cup of coffee like
moths to the flame this is the sense
that we're sort of right at the heart of
things and so the the the two sort of
components that sort of put this
together this is this this notion that
the Bob uses of interconnectedness which
is what do we mean by that so if you
think about collaboration collaboration
is efficient in the sense of the classic
economic a division of labor right so I
do theory you do data I do my theory bit
you do by date a bit we merge them up
off we go
right the you do finance I do some
cryptography we put them together you
know there's your FinTech
interconnectedness is different what you
mean by that is I will teach you my
theory you will teach me your data
techniques and we'll be will have some
of this deeper understanding and so
that's the sense of which is not sort of
this word documents that floats around
different departments getting edited but
this sort of coming together and this
sort of deep understanding in the sense
that you can ask and understand new
questions by understanding what's going
on
finance FinTech is not just finance done
through technology it is the technology
transforming the finance and deep ways
and vice-versa so that the two big
elements that are here and then I'll try
and pass this off to buzz is one is this
location right this note 8 the
description I'd be giving the faculty
members here to try and get that bready
was this is like moving from Fox Chapel
to Lawrenceville right so you know it it
is time to embrace some skinny jeans
a fixed-gear bike right craft beer right
it's gonna be noisy it's gonna be you
know smelly it's like in rewrites it's
very urban experience is lively and
vibrant it is no longer this Country
Club experience with violins in the
background and that that's by design and
then the second component of this is the
fact that and and this is weird you do
not see business schools do this
anywhere else this is a three hundred
thousand square foot building roughly
with which maybe 200,000 square foot is
the Business School there's a hundred
thousand square feet of non-business
school things and for the most part it's
hard to point to places and see which is
which ideally that's yeah exactly
that they sort of blend and mesh but we
have different things living around here
and it's weird the the if you go down
and visit the patty Kenner space where
you're gonna wear some virtual reality
goggles to learn how to speak French
while ordering a Parisian cafe while
feeling egg you're standing right yeah
that's an odd thing to put in a business
school but then you go how can every
Business School not have that the the
last sort of component I will show you
know this slide no not the pond make
many people see my picture of the pond
many times before I and it's a metaphor
that is a much much loved what that one
could say that yes so if you go so how
do you do this so some of the some of
this interconnectedness is organic in
the sense of people are bumping together
and some of this interconnectedness is
more structured so if you look at lots
of the design of the building it is
don't take this the wrong way it's not
very precise in the sense that we didn't
take a classroom and engineer it the way
you typically engineer business school
classrooms by placing seats in strategic
the exactly round places so that you can
you know optimize sight lines and the
professor stands here and five into the
class he Wiggles his right hand at
everybody you know learns dividend
policy or something it is much more
flexible and so this came from a book on
elementary school education which was
trying to sort of challenge the idea
that if people were not sitting in
deaths in rows they could not learn
how to count and so I I don't know
exactly know the story my story I can
just sort of imagine the frustrated
architects and you know I'm tired of
listen to you you want your design
here's your design it's a freaking pond
I'm done right roll it up and and you
think about it can I do all of
elementary school education around a
pond and it shows up you can and so if
you go around the pond you can see in
learning biology and it turns out you
can learn some math and then it turns
out pretty good place for arts and then
you know you think about social you know
society sort of things it turns out lots
of societies live near water for reasons
that are kind of deepen Wow we got the
entire educational experience around the
pond but some of this comes from the
idea of basically not trying to build in
the pedagogy into the building in the
sense of you know there's all kinds of
smart people that work here there's all
kinds of smart people that will be
working here that weren't here when we
started and so much of the building to
sort of design in this sort of foster
that's kind of innovation so all of the
furniture that news is designed to be
moving ok so I'm going to show you one
last picture be proud really into that
pond like I yeah they boo so Ralph
mentioned we had meetings I would like
to show you one particular meeting so if
you notice the person on your left there
that is bending on their arm like this
that this was what we looked like when
we started this project and you'll
notice there's bus fare shortly
thereafter there were there were many
meetings
[Applause]
unbelievable we were very pleased when
Buzz was selected with his team Jeanne
and all the folks that are here and Alan
of landscape partner and multiple others
from Bureau half fold and the rest of
the huge team that it takes to do this
buzz has a a coolness about him can I
tell the story the first story about
David okay not sure I know so we were we
had the first executive steering
committee meeting which was with David
and subra and Jim Rohr and he was
introduced to buzz and we were actually
in and and our former chairman of the
board was there as well ray Lane and
David was sitting across from buzz and
they we were talking you know about
things and and David was very quiet and
he was about this far away I think Brian
you were there and David said buzz what
what's the best campus building that you
know of don't me
[Laughter]
okay no I would never do that David
answer your question
and he just he was so cool in that in
that you know that overhand right that
came there and he's been cool all along
and obviously a thinker very he and
Brian have lots of emails that go back
and forth about very deep topics that I
don't understand but it's a pleasure
working with Buzz and your team Thank
You Ralph it's been really an
extraordinary experience for us and
thrilling it in in many ways just to
follow up on Ralph's comment I think I
was scanning my mind as fast as I could
at my age
and came back and said well I think it's
the Thomas Jefferson's UVA Academical
village and I think it was ray Lane just
jumped in and saved my skin he jumped in
said yes that's the best building and
and campus space in the country so so we
weren't fired so what one thing about
interconnectedness that I think is
special about this project and relates
to things above and Ralph and others
have been saying is that it it exists
within a set of almost nesting scale so
literally to the scale of the region to
the scale of the campus to the scale of
the groups of various sizes to you know
all the way from a thousand people in an
event like what we just add down to one
or two people looking for a quiet place
and a retreat and we also had a very
interesting situation of I think we're
out at one point you said there were 16
prime constituents or something like
that but what made it not only exciting
but relief allowed us collectively to be
successful is that we fairly quickly
developed what we think of as a kind of
high performance team in which everybody
felt empowered to say sometimes
difficult things and to challenge each
other without losing a sense of
collegiality and respect for each other
and that helped us enormously because
the project this complex always has sort
of bumps and valleys and you know we're
working with a fast schedule quite a
tight budget relative to the aspirations
and then we had a fantastic team the
whole connection to the campus and the
inside out with Alan Ward who's here and
and Sasaki the aspirations for
sustainability with Buro Happold a great
associate of Deepak and r3a are here
others that
you've heard about such as my trick is
here it just it was literally scores and
scores of court people and then we had
we have about eight of them here so I
won't go through about Jeanne Chan and
Amy Hellman I think women are better at
keeping a teams together I might get in
trouble for saying that but and then we
had a design review for it with people
like John Carter and Vivienne loftiness
and many others so all these pieces were
just it was iterative we kept cycling
back to all the constituents inviting
all the input and still move fast so one
of the key challenges is how do you take
the great idea which has to do with
interconnectedness which is beyond
collaboration and manifested in all
these scales from the campus scale to
the scale of a room to the scale of
groups or individuals and one thing that
we've felt I'm sorry I was just gonna
yeah has changed order a little bit but
one thing that we felt was very
important was that any building that can
support the sort of vision of a lively
hub that really attracts people from all
across campus but also keeps people here
for long periods of time and also is the
home to the people who live and work in
research and study here and to do that
we think that there needs to be a
diversity of types of space from grand
to intimate of characters of space from
sort of quiet to Lively
from spaces of movement to spaces of
repose from spaces that are for quiet
study to spaces that are for sort of
very active kind of you know breaking
boundaries and barriers so that's a
component that became very important
that we kept testing as we move through
and it was a complement to another key
commitment something that we've really
believed in
of really four decades which is that you
know the best that we can do as a design
team is two great places that celebrate
and nurture community that create places
that people want to be in that are
excited about being in the create places
that support their research their
collaboration and their innovation and
there's some very interesting research
that backs that up Tom Allen who was a
faculty at MIT when we did built a Sloan
School core building there a number of
years ago has some of you may know has
done a lot of research on the
correlation between it's a combination
of distance and visual connection
between people in the community which
essentially says that the lower a
building is so that you're encouraged to
use stairs not elevators the less of a
silo it is the more you can see people
and he and the more you will have a
correlation to thinks he's quantified
such as numbers of interactions and
collaborations and he actually took it
as far in organizations as quantifying
it and comparing these metrics to
numbers of patents which he then related
to innovation so we had always thought
of that as about nurturing community
creating places that people want to be
in we started to understand you know 15
or 20 years ago that it's also
quantitatively and demonstrably
important to the work that a group like
everybody at Carnegie Mellon does it has
physical implications when we started
the the master plan allowed the building
to step up when it got a certain
distance back from Forbes but we decided
for a number of reasons if we could keep
the building to a level as I think
you've experienced where you can see
people you know one or two stories up or
down from you Ralph at a meeting we're
here
few months ago we we all came we didn't
have an exact schedule and we all said
we'll meet in the building and we'll
find each other and it's not how are we
gonna find each other and then I bumped
into Ralph was it the third or fourth
floor ooh their third at this spot and
Ralph said this is where it's one of my
favorite spots but it's also where I
come when I want to bump into people so
there are these kind of Eddie's and
places where the streams intersect and
where these interactions that are
serendipitous happen and which was
supported by the architecture the other
thing about making the building lower is
we were able to really ramp up the ratio
of facade or really skin building
envelope to building volume so we
actually had a three hundred thousand
square foot building that hosts some of
the early programming had the wish list
had gone to about 360,000 but the budget
was much closer to three hundred
thousand so we collectively decided a
number of things that every square foot
had to count that every gesture had to
work in multiple ways that the building
could be I think Ralph use the word that
you know we pride ourselves on being
gritty not fancy here and I'll talk a
little bit more about that later but the
configuration of the building
essentially became five floors one of
which level one is not as big as the
other four but for large floors so there
was a challenge of how do you modulate
the scale we save money by keeping it to
to this big floor plate and often big
floor plates become oppressive but key
to that was the introduction of light
both from the exterior and from the
atria or there's really one atrium hub
with two main sort of zones within it
and we worked with Buro Happold
with the DRV in really studying in great
detail the light levels but also the
views out and the connectivity so
there's light there's comfort there's
views out there's connectivity between
different areas of work that people are
doing and the DRB
I think particularly Viviane and a
couple of others were really standard
bearers for holding the university to
very high standards of every space must
be daylight one of our heroes for those
of us who are probably over a certain
age is Luke on who actually went to
forest to say a space without daylight
is not a space you could argue the that
philosophically but we basically believe
that but we did we almost got stuck on
so we got daylight everywhere I think as
you move through you'll see some of its
what we call borrowed do you see through
a space to the landscape we worked our
team work very hard to to develop sort
of heights where the light could wash
deeply in because there were the floors
to get to a certain height you can wash
deeply in we tried to minimize glare and
try to pick up on connections and
relations to adjacent buildings from the
view point of view but the one place
where we got into this kind of
philosophical discussion was the people
running the behavioral labs wanted them
completely darkened so and we did have
some spaces that like for storage and
for you know changing your clothes etc
that were hard to get light into and we
thought oh perfect one of those spaces
can become and then we had a long
philosophical discussion in the in that
it wasn't that long but in the design
review the board meaning of was it okay
to have darkened spaces for the
behavioral level so as he walks through
the building I think you'll see how
light plays shade and shadow light plays
on the other side of the building and
that connection to this the ability to
maintain their circadian rhythms and
your sense of what buzzword these days
is Biophilia connection to landscape are
all very important to hell you feel in a
building I was thrilled to meet
one of Brian's colleagues is in finance
and who said came up and said I I'm
excited every day when I come into the
building so that experiential and
perceptual part of addressing the
program to us that's part of the program
it's not just meeting the exact
functional needs of had the layouts of
spaces one of the aspects of early
integration of the team and this also
involves PJ dick who was at the table at
the beginning is we want to be
economical we want to have very high
aspirations environmentally that means
every not only every square foot of area
counts we like to say every square foot
counts every dollar counts but ever we
needed to create an integrated system of
structural mechanical finished surfaces
Sun shading interior partitions that
worked as an ensemble and that also led
us expose much of it so there was an
early decision that we were gonna build
a concrete building by using bubble deck
what you see is the voids those open
spaces in this floors it's a system
that's been around Europe and a little
bit in Canada this is the biggest
installation of a bubble deck in North
America but what it does is you can
expose the floor which again has some
trade-offs some people would rather see
you know polished fancier finish you can
expose the ceiling as we did in many
places you can expose the columns you
have to be very careful about how you
warm it up with things like a wood
ceiling how you dampen the acoustics
with things like wood and acoustic
clouds how you you know add color to the
space so you don't feel like you're in a
cold space but you still have the
feeling of being in a loft like space
that you that is not precious that has a
little bit of grittiness and that could
be kind of in a way dressed up in the
right places but just for example the
bubble deck reduced
our load our weight which tracks all the
way down to the foundations it also
reduce our height from steel or in a
steel town so first we all thought well
worst steel town this is where it all
started so are we going against the
grain and in the end the bubble deck
priced out either the same or just a
little bit better than the steel saved
us height which allowed us to get the
right height for all the spaces to be
flexible so they could go from active
learning to tear to laboratory leg
spaces so how all those pieces come
together with underfloor distribution of
air and data in certain places it's sort
of a kit of parts and the other part of
that is at the root at the core of the
success and the resilience of this
building will be flexibility and as much
flexibility as we can possibly bake in
to and design into the building so this
diagram shows the kind of plug-and-play
you heard somebody earlier today say you
know this building should be resilient
and future proof for 10 20 30 40 years
one thing that that flexibility led to
was the ability to plan both traditional
classrooms you see on the upper left
largely tiered classrooms a combination
on the upper right the same space tested
as tiered and flat floor active learning
technology enhanced classrooms and then
where we had a lot of fun and a lot of
this was done in meetings and over the
phone and sometimes between meetings
sketching and holding up the sketches to
the camera and going back and forth with
Brian and Mike and others and was
pushing that to become kind of a
laboratory for teaching and studying so
when you walk through particularly the
upper level of the graduate area you'll
see this really rich mix of informal
meeting but we want it quiet study not
just only open we wanted in innovation
spaces we wanted
coaching spaces and so these spaces can
have that much variation and more over
the next 5 10 20 40 years the idea was
to embed robust infrastructure into a
robust armature and then let there be
lots of chance for variation and you'll
see as you walk through how the kind of
what we call the choreography of
community works how light works how a
lot of the building is really pretty
robust and straightforward like a loft
like the places your students might go
to work but then it's warmed and
animated by color and wood you see here
they're kind of a lot of it is really
what are the bones of the building and
what's great about working with this
concrete system is once it's built
you've got the building you can change
the acoustics you can change the amount
of detail and richness you can rough it
up it's meant to be used and tested and
the fact and then it's meant to create
many many kinds of neighborhoods this is
one of the faculty neighborhoods which
has a white a kind of bar at the far end
who's back by sort of white white boards
so every place every inch that we could
support connectivity interconnectedness
collaboration and and a sense of feeling
good in the building happens throughout
building that's it under construction
the agretti's estonia the graduate
domain you'll see which is flexible can
have the entire graduate cohort the
sliding doors to classrooms open up so
it's got many many variations it's kind
of that's it under construction it's
like a transformer and the
undergraduates David was very and Jeff
were very determined that the
undergraduates had a home base but we
overlapped boundaries so here the
undergraduates upper level is very close
to entrepreneurship and can share an
innovation hub with them
and that's a little farther along and so
we were gonna go Thank You buzz
I'm sure we'll have Andrew Riley is our
director construction and engineering
he's actually a senior director and he
hates me saying that cuz he he says it
makes him sound old but I may be but I
just don't want to hear
Andrews phenomenal Andrew has a very
very patient but once the fuses gets lit
get out of the room because there's no
contractors that can be s Andrew because
he's been on the other side and he knows
how these things work and great with
systems and contract language and
everything else fantastic addition to
our team we stole them we after he built
Posner and also PTC Andrew economic and
our old colleague Joe Greenaway said you
got to get this guy and we brought
Andrew in specifically to build gates
Hillman and now he's the director so
let's talk about construction Andrew
sure first like to thank our contractors
that with great great contractors and
subcontractors BJ dick lighthouse became
ish I don't see many of them around here
today but we had a work appreciation
event a few months but they did a great
job and we really appreciate all the
work we had we peaked around 275 workers
on site over over the approximately
three year period it all started in
summer 2015 this is a utility crossing
is not a tunnel Brian and Bob wrote
across another Forbes Avenue we didn't
want to call it a tunnel because people
were asking us to build a tunnel under
either a bridge over a ton of wander for
the connectivity for people now the
reason why that we don't put people in
this this is 28 feet down the yellow
shirts those are people down there right
under Forbes Avenue
so one picture is the first half going
across from Hillman and the picture on
the right the second half coming on it
on The Temper side now I had to vote
half the time during the summer so in a
10-week period we put that 28 feet under
the under the
that was summer 2015 we had the
groundbreaking in October 2016
the had moved about 12,000 cubic 216
thousand cubic yards of Earth and dirt
to make way for this I got to check my
notes for my figures here for to make
make the pad for the building you can
see we're right up against Central's
football field the and the rock was a
big big discussion big value management
thing we had to do right we kind of
built the building into the rock to try
and save some money once again trying to
get much much space as we could as
cheaply as we could so we we kind of
stepped a building into the rock layer
so we weren't digging out the rock which
is ten times more expensive than just
digging regular dirt we had we had a lot
of sustainability issues sustainability
process at the building's LEED Gold
worldly certified LEED Gold in the
construction process we have to this
sounds terrible but there's a good side
to it here over 2,100 tons of waste
generated in our building process of
that 2100 tons
2,000 tons have been recycled so 95% of
the waste going off the site from
leftover crates pallets drywall
everything to 95% was recycled so it's a
great great staff for us the other one
is the cistern down the very lower
right-hand far back right corner of this
picture as a sister and that holds a
higher twenty thousand gallons of water
which just on which is a huge storm
water runoff issue in Pittsburgh as you
all know about the floods and things
it's really helped us that that water
used to go down Forbes Avenue and down
to the bridge and blow the manhole lid
off down at CIC driveway when we had
these rains and and everything that
hasn't happening more water still comes
out just as doesn't blow that
holding it off because we're capturing
most of that now in the ring just the
rain on Sunday we estimated on our
60,000 square foot roof the rain on
Sunday was three and three-quarter
inches of rain and that was a hard
15,000 gallons of water so our cisterns
already full as buz mentioned the bubble
deck these are the there was - around
220,000 bubbles placed in the building
they were hard plastic balls size of
like kick balls the the reason of all
the colors people kept asking us the
colors mean something is there something
to tune and it was not nothing at all it
really was the manufacture of them was
in New Kensington and they also make
kayaks so they were taking their spare
either recycling misfits or extra runs
at the end of a day and making balls out
of it when they're making their kayaks
so they're the same thing that it's in
kayaks struck and the principles of of
that right is you create and which what
gives us the great volume what I love is
is the great volume that we get because
the sense without any beams through the
space we can take the ductwork and put
it right up to the ceiling
right you don't have to drop down
underneath the 24 inch beam somewhere so
we gain that whole volumes that gives us
all these great high ceilings because
because the slab itself becomes the beam
right you get a top chord and bottom
chord the way an i-beam steel i-beam
works I could talk about that for a long
time these please don't Andrew the other
the other big thing we had was the Tri
court trust that's out here in the front
of the atrium it's what they believe or
not that glass wall at the front of the
building everything from above the
vestibule above the roof of the
vestibule is hung down off of this tri
court trust that's why you don't see the
fins of that of that glass wall come all
the way down to the floor they stop
because it's literally hung down and
holds it so this was a huge
momentous occasion when we put that
track or dress in place the key to
construction of such a large project and
I say this because my nemesis is in this
picture because it's still exist out
there that telephone pole that's leaning
there's a Verizon wire wire wireless
Wi-Fi access hold if they have
authorization from the city to put that
in and we have just been battling back
and forth to try and get it taken out
our new like our new light poles that
we're putting in will have capacity
thanks to Okarche and like we'll have
capacity to take that wireless antenna
that sits on top of that pole and put it
inside the light pole the new light
poles we have just we're waiting for the
those particular light poles to show off
that they go into so but communication
is the key even it gets you even if
you're fighting that communication
company over all the I also like to
thank Central Catholic they were a great
neighbor for us and a great ally in our
process we drastically changed their
landscape as you if anyone remembers
there was a wooded hillside and you know
they were pretty remote down there in
the bottom it's completely changed and
I'd like to also thank our team
Mike Kelly Brennan garrison no car speed
and our business operations groups I'll
land back there again thing thank her
too Greg McDowell is here he was part of
the civil package doing that utilities
come to site so I want to thank all of
them the also what was important was to
get to this finished product was you
know we we tried things out we did a big
mock-up out there and we tried things
out and as you said it was a great team
effort to help figure out solve things
thank you Andrew I mentioned Jeff before
he we've had lots of meetings here with
the executive steering committee and
usually about two hours later Bryan and
I were on the phone with Jeff saying
here we go
and Jeff would work it out and we'd come
back together and fix something we did
that dozens of times and Jeff has been
phenomenal to work with obviously astute
at business but astonishingly good at
design and things aesthetic as well
which has been a huge help to us in
terms of interpreting things with David
but Jeff asked for one slide
there's Lori weingartz signed a bubble
but Jeff asked for one slide on time on
budget whisper don't me
all day just just to finish this this
being wonderful group one time on budget
is is obviously more of a business
philosophy that Dave and myself were
trying to bring to this project we
obviously had the architectural
dimensions the execution dimensions in a
lot of talent that was brought to this
team and Dave was looking to me to make
sure not that the project was so much on
time on budget I mean that that is our
slogan but it's really on strategy and
on point it was so much more important
than although we did and
meeting with Ralph Brian are we on time
and on budget
yeah that's Geoff and every email was
the same and and it was within honesty
because they're all very conscious of
our goals but the on strategy on point
was you know there was a strategic
vision that buzz and others have
articulated better than myself even
David as presenting this as an idea not
just the building and our job was to
fill the building with a heart and soul
and to give it sort of his signature but
really the school signature you know
that that's part of a job that that I
hope to take on on Dave's behalf and
on-budget really on point was really in
teka bollec Secutor because you can
imagine the enormous amount of time
spent on detail and we're all detail
oriented in different ways and I'm a
finance guy with some some visual acuity
and acumen and you know I would come out
and we talk about handmade brick and
here's the slab of handmade bricks and
you know a planet cornerstone and finish
on the columns and the mix of glass to
steel and you know fortunately I was the
one who could react almost as Delaine
and not just on day's behalf but as a
lay person amongst experts to make sure
that this sort of generational building
was being interpreted in a way that that
we and the donor soul as as the right
direction and then it was being
perfectly executed by a team as good as
any in this country and maybe the world
so I was proud to be a part of it we had
we had a few little story lines and
vignettes along the way that I would say
we're interesting for me you know a
couple of snippets I remember you know
we always have to schedule a meeting
every so often I'm finding day it's like
witness-protection where's he gonna be
South Beach
Short Hills New York
so you know it's in a good mood how's
that pellucid doing these are finally
choreographed meetings and one of the
first ones we had with buzz and always
Ralph and Brian and team we're
renderings of the building like things
that Dave and I can see and appreciate
and came into the office and presented
some initial ideas and Dave looked at me
and I looked at Dave and with the buzz
and Brian and Dave said to me what do
you think these words for I want to be
more inspired by the building brilliant
I said I want to be more inspired by you
and I think buzz totus correct that as
great you know this is a guy who you
know it's not just the money it's not
just the function it's not just a
building it's like let's make this
transcendent and you know let's have not
just a functional vision and a
generational vision but an aesthetic
vision and Buzz and team really Ralph
Umbro we all did we changed it and we
made it inspirational and our minds and
our eyes is a big building first look
there was like that looks like a
big schoolhouse you know it's like let's
let's turn it into something and it
never was going to be that things were
just initial renderings but for us to
see it and you know the team took the
challenge and then we had like very
mundane meetings and Bob Orr and II
references whether it was digging into
granite I remember we had a call was
like well we need a second level of
parking but we have all this bedrock you
know what are we gonna do it's gonna
cost more our food raise more money
we'll compromise the schedule and this
Dave says I'm usually the hammer but the
hammer would the velvet glove which is
like all right let's figure it out it's
not just because it won't be on budget
that we can't do it but let's figure out
what the right answer is what's most
important we didn't do the second level
and it wasn't core to the mission you
know everyone just sorted through the
priorities of you know we want a lot of
things but but what do we need and then
as importantly we had a wonderful finish
from graduation to today then this
building was largely done when we were
here in May but you know like a house
becoming a home
it needed finishes and you know part of
my job with Ralph with no signage was
finishing landscaping was finishing I
mean all the landscape architecture I
mean as much time as you all we all
spent on that to finish this as
important as it is when I came up here
this morning
and I just kind of looked up and said
boy it's perfect right so the finish was
part of this impeccable execution so
anyway I was privileged to be a part of
the team and you know the words we're a
collaboration was the word we used it's
like all over the building the students
but collaboration amongst this team
phenomenal communication great and
confidence in one another we try to role
for them was a full-time job it was a
part-time job but we all depended on
each other and there's a lot of
confidence in that and it was a real
tribute to
[Applause]
thank you Jeff
thank you very much any questions we'd
love to hear whatever curiosities
anybody might have I'm gonna ask Brian
Rutledge a question in that case as a
question Ralph I got a question over
here
well then please so let's open this one
[Laughter]
yeah here we go
oh wait wait Bob masterplan slide sorry
sorry sorry we're reliving our
presentation yeah so as you can see the
temper quad is the building obviously on
the left and then the the actual
landscape quad and then those other
buildings are actually building
footprint sites in our institutional
master plan but the landscape as you can
see runs north towards Fifth Avenue will
always be maintained so where you see a
parking lot outside that's that's a
future building site when you see
parking behind the building towards WQED
that's a future building site so good
question it's worth noting - I would
like to point is that that crossing that
you see where the red and kind of light
blue era or the one right out of here
that goes to Hillman that was we started
playing that cross and in 2006 both
utilities and the people crossing that
space we did we had no idea was that
there was the business total meeting
here at Bob and Ralph started playing
that back in 2006 there's a question
over yes please
that in in in GSA a it will be the
master's program in the School of Art
and also the School of Music will be in
there and in posner it's a series of
things mostly deitrick related but also
then student success of a big home for
student success and a series of ten
classrooms that were Temper only
classrooms will turn out back to the
registrar so it's a it's a super win for
the university as a whole I was coming
to the head of Fine Arts that they're
taking over what used to be you know
finance faculty offices of turning them
into like an artist studio and that it
was a shame that this gentrification was
making it so that you know investment
bankers couldn't afford an office
anymore for weird direction but makes me
kind of happy questions yes ma'am
that's like buzz take a crack at that
first maybe I think well since Brian's
been teaching he should but I'll just
say a couple things and throw it back to
Brian though I mean as architects what
what we really live for is how spaces
are experienced and used so just we it's
been a few months since I've been here
Amy's been coming every every few weeks
but seeing it actually opened up and
hearing from people who say I come here
even though I'm not part of the school
to hang out and I find my favorite place
and some other people saying I'd like
the diversity you know I somebody might
want to be way up high and somebody may
want to be tucked away so you know so
that kind of diversity of the Commons in
a way rather than a we've done other
buildings that have great atria but not
the richness of choice it's like the
pond that you can find your place in the
in the ecosystem and I think Brian
should really talk about the teaching
and the faculty and we haven't been here
that long in a sense to see but I mean I
think the hope is that people will use
it in space in ways we hadn't seen
before and you know there's certainly
lots of students sort of hopping and
these little perching in these little
places and I think that was intended
about the guy understood what that meant
and it's you know you walk past it's
it's fun to see people you know living
the bill it is busy in the sense that it
it is successful since I have not been
to the building when it's quiet in the
sense of when you don't have this kind
of buzz and feel to it so they're the
food service we talked to we tend to do
this thing of whenever we visit
buildings we ask everybody with it
what works and what doesn't but we
talked to somebody in food service and
they they said the lines were there were
the number of meals and the demand was
higher than they expected although they
they're gonna roll out a and I I phone
or app so you can order and pick up
which so there's they're kind of like
settling in trying to understand
flows so this morning I was told by Dean
Damon that there was a graduate student
who had office hours out here oh and he
had the little paper signup and it was
for psychology 101 that's right out here
right out here oh I love it so yep my
answer to all of this is it's a feature
not a bug I thought I saw another hand
but there was another oh yes please
oh it is going to flush we use it to
flush the toilets and urinals
so we pump pump it back through the
building of a group called a grey water
system
yeah and I think there are a couple but
somebody else haven't had it hand raised
back there okay all right well I think
we're actually right on time but we can
stay as long as anybody wants and if you
want to come up but I have to I have to
give Brian Rutledge the last word it's
been a tremendous honor working with you
on this and we're gonna have you on lots
of committees awesome to report only
thing I'd point out was that the big
strategic decision we made early on the
one that was absolutely the most
important and lived by this if you learn
nothing from this panel this is it we
did not have any committees there were
no committees on this you will note that
Ralph and I were the chair of the
working group it was not a committee we
are working come to our meetings all you
want you're welcome to come but we are
working group we're not a committee
we've had we did this whole project
there wasn't one vote so I mean do any
poll voting we didn't do any it was
we're just gonna sit here until we
figure it out and we all agree or we
yell at one another or all of those
things happen so but thank you rob it
has been an honor and a privilege so
working with everybody we are very lucky
to have had buzz and team on Ralph's
group is spectacular to work with as
well as the
all the folks who worked at you know our
local folks that are 3a and Peach a
decade is amazing to watch it all come
together because it's a you know every
bolt and screw at some point somebody
decided on a place and it's amazing that
that all happens and the you know here
we are so anyway thank you all wonderful
thanks everybody thank you all for
coming thank you very much